[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle cynthia abraham je
vais vous chanter regarder danser je
vous laisse regarder et je vous retrouve
tout de suite après pour vous expliquer
pourquoi j'ai composé ce morceau est
pourquoi j'ai choisi
[Musique]
pendant ces 4 à 7 ans et l'on se
souvient
pourtant c'est pas lancer qu'un set en
cédant ce sourire à la vie
su émerveiller la grc avait
[Musique]
lancé sa couleur et s'en amuse et
400 sous
[Musique]
la
souris facile mais la voir dans ces
troubles
regardez là c'est sa route et se sont
amusés
[Musique]
471 dans ce sous la pluie
devant servir aux dégâts dans sept ans
et on se souviendra plus
[Musique]
le jour
samson
reviennent
et ne sais pas et de tancer
en silence
en scellant
bye bye bye bye bye rester tandis qu'il
a regardé danser
et
la beauté de ce bye bye bye
enchanté c'est du temps sorte mais je la
vois dans cette approche paul et
m'évader jamais regarder danser sa robe
flotter sans l'amusé
[Musique]
tout en démesure et 14 7 ans et on se
sourit à la vie
tout en démesure et 407 ans et on se
souvient l'office
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un crochet
la
regarder
et douce elle a posé
cette transe son élégance
son élégant
oh
et bye bye bye bye
et il est enfin allé danser
il va y
[Musique]
rester c'est la beauté de ce bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye
aussi je suis allée danser
pas ici
[Musique]
j'ai écrit regardez dans cest juste
avant le confinement avant d'enregistrer
mon tout dernier album c'est un morceau
qui célèbre la vie qui célèbre la joie
qui célèbre l'humanité et qui célèbre
aussi la femme donc c'était important
pour moi que qu'il rentre dans ce cadre
de la femme créole puissante et voilà
c'est un morceau qui appelle à la danse
et à la célébration
tandis qu'ils regardent
je vous retrouve très vite pour un
prochain concert prenez soin de vous
retrouvez moi sur les réseaux sociaux je
m'appelle cynthia abraham a très très
peu du temps sans semer la mort
[Musique]